I wanted to try nitrous oxide to help with the pain in my thighs that I think is from
a lack of oxygen from Bartonella is and oh, safe to take with horrible positive breast
cancer.
Well, we first need to clarify this, okay, so nitrous oxide versus nitric oxide.
I think what this person is asking is nitric oxide.
So nitrous oxide is a gas.
That's what has been called laughing gas that is still used in the dental industry to
take away pain.
Can you get nitrous oxide as a therapy to use for pain in your thighs?
I don't believe so.
But it is used to numb the brain neural center so you don't feel things.
That's why it's used to the dental industry.
So when you get laughing gas at the dentist, it is nitrous oxide.
That has negative things to its usage.
So I don't think that's what this person is asking, but I want to clarify that.
And I also want to say that getting is a good time to talk about nitrous oxide as a dental
as a use in dentistry, the negative about nitrous oxide is that it has been shown to completely
shut down the methylation pathway for I think up to like two hours.
I think the study show.
So it will literally block everything down stream for methylation for up to two hours.
So it can have some huge negative side effects.
So I don't ever recommend using nitrous oxide when you go to the dentist for that reason.
But I don't think this person is talking about nitrous oxide.
I think they're talking about nitric oxide.
Very different.
Nitric oxide is something to help stimulate blood flow.
What it does is it increases what's called vascular endothelial growth factor.
Nitric oxide is used in a lot of supplements that people would use whether doing workouts.
It can help increase blood flow to the muscles.
It can help with pain, whether it's constriction of the blood flow to an area, nitric oxide will
increase blood flow.
It can help with cardiovascular help.
It's used in a lot of supplements for cardiovascular issues because it helps increase cardiovascular
flow.
What nitric oxide does is it affects the smooth muscle tissue below the endothelial layer that
lines the capillaries.
It causes vascular dilation because it attaches to certain receptors on those muscles and it
causes relaxation.
So therefore it causes vasodilation.
So it can decrease blood pressure.
So nitric oxide is great to help with people with high blood pressure.
It's great to help overall healing of the heart because it will stimulate vascular endothelial
growth factor which will stimulate more blood vessel production anywhere in the body.
So the heart is definitely needed to have extra what's called an asthmocene vessel.
So you get vessels that are growing to add vascularization to the heart.
So if I have blockage in some of my smaller capillaries of the heart without an asthmocene
vessel that I could end up having a heart attack, so nitric oxide is a perfect supplement
for cardiovascular problems.
However, with anybody with any cancer other than blood cancers like leukemia, but any cancer
that is what's called a solid tumor cancer, which also includes lymphoma.
So breast cancer, any cancer that is not leukemia or multiple myeloma, put it that way.
So any cancer other than leukemia and multiple myeloma, nitric oxide sets it increases vascular
endothelial growth factor.
It can also increase growth of blood vessels into a cancer, increasing the ability for cancer
to grow faster.
So what is the purpose in both alternative cancer therapy and standards of care cancer therapy
is to decrease vascular endothelial growth factor.
We don't want to be doing things that increase vascular endothelial growth factor.
So nitric oxide would be contraindicative in any heart or solid tumors, any tumors other
than leukemia or multiple myeloma.
So if you have leukemia or multiple myeloma, then it really isn't the heart of a taking
nitric oxide.
If you have any other than leukemia or multiple myeloma, then you should not be taking nitric
oxide.
Now, the struggle with that comment is what if a person has a comorbidity of cardiovascular
disease that's not uncommon, just because you have cancer, doesn't mean you don't have
cardiovascular disorders as well, very common, number of causes that to the United States
is cardiovascular disorders.
So how do you balance that?
I have very high blood pressure, I have no, I have blocked arteries, I know I have vascular
issues, and I don't want to die of cancer, but I also don't want to die of cardiovascular
disease.
Well, if your cancer is in a relative state of remission, then I would say that you're
probably okay taking nitric oxide.
If you're not in a state of remission at all, or you don't know that you are in a state
of remission, then I would not be taking nitric oxide.
So again, nitric oxide is not considered safe to take.
For people with solid tumors, they need any tumors other than leukemia and multiple
myeloma, because it increases vascular endothelial growth factor and it could increase the vascularization
of that tumor and increase the growth of that tumor.
So no, it's not safe to take a lot of it.